you're not coming last salaam alaikum
greetings of peace to all the viewers
all over the globe there is a tragic
event that happened in Boston
what are we as Muslims once or submitted
to the will of God who live Islam
they're trying to call Islam radical
putting the name in front of it is that
something that you can do what's our
response is Islam encourage this we want
every human being who's sincere and
wants to know the truth every politician
every president has tuning in because
they like the D show they know if they
want to learn about Islam the way of
life from the crater they tuned into the
Dean shell so we're going to be giving
you the response the truth here from the
Muslims what do we have to say about
this Boston bombing let me come back if
our next guest will be right back
the
[Music]
this is the wine it comes in today
Ricardo how are you how are you I'll
handle everybody thank you for joining
us you know so it's sad when we hear
such news that's out there we're trying
hard to share this message of peace
Islam is a way of peace is from the
Creator it's not a man-made religion
it's a way of life that Jesus lived
Moses they all submitted to the will of
God and we as those who are living in
America we're trying our best to share
this beautiful way of life that brings
peace contentment satisfaction to the
human being tells him what the purpose
of life is without any doubt remaining
in the human being when he investigates
it picks up the Quran and sees what's it
all about but now you see we take one
step forward to take two step back when
we hear it saddens us those are our
brothers in humanity you know when the
bombs go off and now people take this
opportunity you know the people that are
the Islamophobes and people that just
had that hate in their heart and they
start putting radical in front of Islam
and you know so we did we wanted to do
the show to have our voice heard what's
the first thing that came to your mind
when you saw these Boston events happen
and the bombs going up over the Fraser
as an American Muslim here
bismillahirrahmanirrahim I start in the
name of Allah God the most beneficent
the most merciful and greet all of you
with the Islamic greeting of assalamu
alaykum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh who
may peace mercy and blessings of our
Almighty God be upon each single one of
us each single one of you when we hear
when we see the images of the bombing in
Boston the very first thing that comes
to our mind is that innocent people are
dying our hearts our prayers are going
to those innocent victims and the second
very important fact obviously as a
Muslim would be
oh Allah Oh God let that not be Muslim
let it not be Muslim the reason that
thought comes to the mind is because
unfortunately people sometimes judge the
faith the ideology but the actions of
some of his followers so we don't want
anyone for that matter to judge Islam
but the tragic events that happened so
there's the flurry first and foremost
thing that was crossing my mind so let's
let's we're gonna ask the questions that
are on the minds of the people okay
people are many of them were tuned in
are open-minded and it's like you know
what I'm not going to believe the mass
media Fox News you know and all the
other media outlets out there that are
creating hysteria and now you know
everybody's scared of the Muslims making
it out like these are the boogeyman
coming to get you what does we're Muslim
now okay we live by the Koran the
verbatim Word of God the way of life
that I always say was lived by Jesus
Moses Abraham they were all Muslims they
submitted to the will of God we love
Muslims is this true I mean we love
Jesus is that true they live all the
prophets and the day the Jesus the
Muhammad the Moses that any of them call
or for us as those who live this way of
life encourage this kind of behavior
does Islam encourage this kind of
behavior
killing indiscriminate men women and
children you know planting a bomb and
just putting it out there at a marathon
in a Pizza Hut wherever does Islam
encourage this definitely not definitely
not on top of it Islam came to eradicate
terrorism so Islam wants to have a jihad
against terrorism if you want to put
like it that way so we have a copy of
the Quran appear it's very important
that the Quran has 114 chapters in there
not a single one of them in sight or
encourages people to ha to harm or to
kill anyone out there not one not a
single verse on top of it we have
volumes and volumes of the sayings and
examples of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him not a single one of his actions
his sayings or interactions ever
promoted or encouraged terrorism
on top of it all over the Quran and in
the example of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him the main theme is to unite
humanity under one Brotherhood one
sisterhood so we could all worship the
one creator by by bringing justice and
peace to the world in fact there is a
very important statement in the Quran
chapter 49 verse number 60 verse number
13 of the Quran where the Creator is
saying in the quran that o humanity we
have created you from one single meal
and one single female and have made you
into nations and tribes and different
cultures and different backgrounds that
you may get to know each other not that
you may despise each other this is the
crater speaking in the verbatim word of
god the quran right there what about is
there anything in there that that would
give justification for someone to go
ahead and plant a bomb there's nothing
that now you know someone can use and
say okay look the Quran is you know
advocating that I kill my my Christian
neighbor my Jewish neighbor you know to
take over and just annihilate everybody
who's not Muslim there's nothing that
there is nothing in the Quran on top of
it this there are verses in the Quran
that speaks about how to take care of
the oppressed
how to fight injustice and oppression
around the world and if you may allow I
could give you some of this example so
our wonderful viewers who are
open-minded sincere want to learn about
Islam would be educated about the
wonderful teachings now is this book
locked up where you don't have access to
it so people can go actually check for
themselves to see maybe you're pulling
the wool over their eyes they can go
actually look this up to go read it yes
in fact so I'm not just going to
generally mention what the Quran is
saying I will give the exact reference
both the chapter and also the worst
number so first and foremost it says in
the Quran in chapter number 2 verse
number 1 9 0 to be exact
that fight in the cause of God for those
who fight against you but do not cause
oppression and do not transgress the
limits set by God
so if anyone is coming after you your
property your wife your children your
your wealth you have the god-given right
to pick up arms to defend yourselves
very important so that's in the context
of self-defense and in war there are
some rules of engagement yeah so that's
in there there are those verses all
right and obviously what are some of
those rules of engagement first and
foremost was to save guide to safeguard
the life and sanctity of life it says in
the Quran chapter number 5 verse number
32 they're taking one innocent life is
like taking the life of all of humanity
and saving one innocent life is like
saving the life of all of humanity so
there's how much Islam respects and
honors the life not just of a Muslim it
doesn't say life of a Muslim here life
of anyone who is out there innocent on
top of it it also says that if the enemy
it says in Chapter number eight verse
number 61 then if the enemy is inclining
towards peace then you also inclined
towards peace you know join hands make a
peace treaty and work towards justice
and peace and it also says in a just war
make sure that you do not kill women and
children and non-combatants that is the
saying of Prophet Mohammed peace be upon
him no killing of children women or
innocent people
no carpet bombing there is no he Moshe
there is no Nagasaki and Hiroshima in
Islam you cannot you know in a drop
bombs on the population you cannot
destroy houses of worship do not cut
down the trees and the resources and the
water resources and in the cable lines
clear teachings of Islam these are clear
teachings in Islam either in the Koran
directly or in the sayings of Prophet
Mohammed before we go to break there's
someone out there we got a lot of not
yet Muslim because everyone has the
potential to do what Jesus did Jesus
submitted not to himself not to - to
anyone other than the Creator that
happens on earth and that's what a
Muslim is one who submits to the will of
God some people might say man these guys
are the Antichrist these heathens
they're trying to kill us and take our
freedoms away what you say to him
well very important the name of Jesus
mentioned 25 times in the Quran with
honour and respect and you know at most
importance not just him his mother is
respected in the Quran it says that in
chapter number 19 the whole the whole
chapter is named after Mary the mother
of Jesus peace be upon her so there is
no reference in the Quran just to sum up
about two insight or to encourage
violence however there are verses in the
Quran to promote peace and justice for
all of humanity okay we're gonna take a
break and we're right back with more
talking about the Boston bombing Islam
has nothing to do with it it's condemned
by Islam there's no justification for it
in Islam we right back with more here in
the D show
[Music]
who
[Music]
show us the way to other screens this is
the D did a visa this is the D do you
nervous it's a way of life brought to us
been the messenger best of me show us
the way to alice Chris this is the Dean
Dean Allison had a lot but handily
laughs but now he'll a high in nah nah
nah egg bomb I love egg bound
I'm so glad Allah open hamdulillah I'm
gonna heal a high in na na na egg bomb I
love egg bomb a lot but hamdulillah but
la ilaha illallah w'allahu akbar i love
egg bound subhanAllah oh and hamdulillah
I'm gonna heal aha in na na na egg bound
I love egg bomb Allah alhamdulillah la
illaha illa ma love egg bomb I love egg
bomb subhanAllah Oh and hamdulillah la
la la la I love egg bomb why is our news
media foaming at the mouth when it comes
to stories about Islamic terrorists but
not white guy terrorists is that because
Muslims are a bigger threat in fact
between 1980 and 2005 94% of all the
attempted or successful terrorist
attacks on US soil were not carried out
by Islamic radicals but instead by
non-muslims most
white guys so then why the obsession
it's killing of innocent human beings
human life is precious back here on the
Dean show and we're talking about my
favorite subject purpose of life why
we've been created why we here and it
all revolves around this way of life
this way of life that promotes peace
purpose and provides all the solutions
to humanity's problems so when we take
strong exception to when it's vilified
when you put radical in front of Islam
yeah you have a lot of radically insane
people out there right so we know that
these as you said earlier there's no
justification Islam condemns it we
condemn it but many of the not yet
Muslims are brothers in humanity want
they want to know we've had scholars on
this program before we've had you all so
you know acts like 9/11 and all these
other evil acts we've condemned it we've
talked about it and clearly put Islam
has nothing to do with this okay you got
lunatics all over the place right so
what do we have to say about this very
short answer muslims are condemning it
we're not just condemning this act of
terrorism what happened in boston on 911
events we have to be very fair we have
to condemn any act of any terrorism done
by anyone by the way may that be a
muslim or a non-muslim for that matter
the drone missile missiles that have
killed thousands of people especially in
Pakistan in Iraq and Afghanistan and
Yemen
you know some people are dying and we as
Muslims we want to condemn any
oppression which is taking place but
that's not a fair question brother Eddie
I'm not going to ask a Mexican which I
am going to find on the street saying
that you know are you condemning what is
going on in Mexico all the drug cartels
they're killing and murdering and
shooting people I'm not going to ask
every Jewish person which I find on the
street or a Jewish organization are you
condemning every single act of terrorism
done by some of the Jews up there so
there's not a fair question the fair
question would be
what does Islam says about that act or
what does Islam says about humanity
fighting oppression bringing justice and
peace so that will be a better question
than a question of condemnation but the
bottom line is every single organization
I mean I belong to Islamic circle of
North America if you go to our website
ignore --g icy and a dot o-r-g right on
the front page of a national president
by the name big he has a statement of
condemnation
it's na ki r ik na Maya mana every
single organization we have condemned it
so we should be very fair not only
condemning this act but condemning act
of any terrorism done by anybody who is
out there so condemning killing innocent
people in Afghanistan in in in any any
country Pakistan you mentioned some
other countries here in America if we're
going to be we need to be consistent all
around but even if someone does come and
do something unjust that doesn't give us
a green light to go do something unjust
of course of course you know when we are
discussing or comparing and contrasting
we are not saying that yes Muslims are
doing it and you guys are also doing it
we are on the same page we're not saying
that at all
what we are saying is do not judge the
wonderful faith of Islam but the actions
of a few people were misguided if you
want to judge Islam pick up the Quran
read what our creator has mentioned in
there and examine the life of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him so tell us
now ok so you've had it's really sad you
know we want every as I open to show
every president politician every
lawmaker in in America to to come to us
and to talk with us go into the mosque
talk to the Muslims talk to your
neighbors so I must and talk to you the
doctors engineers who are serving you
who are law-abiding citizens and talk
with them engaged right of course you
know there was a study on done in
I think it was Duke University CNN had
published her talking about this whole
theater a threat how it's been
exaggerated you know so when you get
down to talking and you look at the
facts you know at the fiction you'll see
that that you know even though Muslims
are 1.5 1.6 billion in every religion
you know especially a huge one like this
you're gonna have a few bad apples of
the bunch you're gonna have some people
who are radically insane but can you say
radical Islam because you see this you
know they were radicalized radical Islam
and you don't hear the contrast the
opposite radical Christianity if someone
like Timothy McVeigh you know and some
of the other people who have done
horrific acts why you know can you
actually say that radical Islam
definitely there's a misnomer if anyone
says a radical Islam there's not fear
because if you look into the Quran and
the example of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him there is one Islam one Islam
which has been projected in the Quran
and implemented and practiced by Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him so it's not
fair to attach any label to any religion
for that matter because as you have as
you know and everyone else knows that no
one is perfect
we have Hall all committed since some of
our followers may have committed heinous
acts followers of the faith so it's not
fair to judge Christianity for example
by the actions what happened in the
Crusades Inquisition or what that
Norwegian person and race Brevik
murdering 77 people in the name of
Christianity and motivated by some of
the Islam of hopes they had the Virginia
Tech guy he killed like what almost 30
people 93 people correct yeah and what
was his quote he had a quote he said
thanks to you I died like Jesus died
right
you don't blame Christianity for this
lunatics the behavior do we of course
not you know I mean Muslims who are
listening over here do not blame
Christianity for what people are doing
in the name of Christ do not be mislead
what some Muslims are doing in the name
of Islam you know if you run through
every single country there are people
who are going to use or abuse the name
of their faith for
example in Romania itself there is a
Christian organization called as the
iron gate they are Roman Catholics and
they are putting bombs and they are
killing their fellow people of other
Christian sects in Ireland you also have
a group called the orange volunteers
these are fundamental Protestant
Christians who are putting bombs in the
Catholic churches if you go to Uganda
wait you have the National Lib you have
that the Lord's Resistance Army there
they are causing havoc they are raping
and sending child soldiers and they're
murdering anyone else who is not a
Christian in India you have the you have
the group called the National Liberation
of Tripura they are force converting
people are Hindus to Christianity right
and anyone who does not do it they're
killing them right and left I mean I
have the whole list over here of every
single act that they have done
you know since 2000 up until now you
have tons of examples you can give more
recently it has James Holmes the The
Dark Knight movie Massacre killed 14
people you know I was told that his
neighbors were saying or one of his
family said he was heavily involved in
his local Presbyterian Church so he was
he was a Christian and but but the the
media looked at it like let's go a
little bit deeper and see what's in his
mind this guy maybe you know why they
didn't just label him Christian radical
radical right debtor is terrorist so we
have to be very fair and just we gotta
be fair there are bad apples in every
community and every followers if you are
going to if I'm going to destroy Islam
based on the actions of a few Muslims
then we have to let go of any faith
which is out there because every single
follower is a sinner
we don't blame every Christian now
Catholic for all the pedophilia that's
going on with all the priests out there
do we we sale okay you know every
Christian is a pedophile now because of
what the majority of the priests have
done how do we of course not so there's
not fearing just so it's very important
for you me and everyone else to separate
the actions of the followers and they
could be doing all of these heinous acts
because of emotions because of their
lack of understanding of the faith or
getting brainwashed or taking things out
of context or they could be in a
frenzied nature of mentality suppose for
example if your parents getting killed
by drone missiles for example bombing
your properties getting destroyed your
children your your wealth is getting
destroyed so a person may have emotional
frenzy because of that he or she could
be doing sin these acts just like for
example one of our own fellow Americans
when when the Iraq war was going on
they're supported by 93 percent because
of emotions but later on when logically
when they looked into the situation they
found out that there's not the fact that
was not the right thing to do so it's
very important to separate the wonderful
faith of Islam by the actions of a few
misguided people then to read the Quran
examine the life of Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and you will
appreciate the wonderful guidance of the
creator
we're gonna go on we're gonna I'm gonna
ask you some more about this and we're
gonna take a break Boston bombing
civilians in Afghanistan Iraq Yemen
Pakistan wherever innocent people are
dying we condemned it across the board
there's no justification we got to keep
repeating it because some people just
can't hear is Lomb ain't got nothing to
do with it
islam is about promoting peace peace
with your creator peace within yourself
and then peace with the rest of mankind
and we've agreed eachother with Salam
peace we'll be right back I started
asking deeper questions the question I
want people to really ask themselves is
when you come back from a night on the
town
you've been drinking you've been boozing
you've been dancing
hanging out with girls guys whatever
number one did you improve yourself is
human being number two did you
contribute anything to the betterment of
humanity the amazing thing is is that
the most advanced studies and psychology
about human happiness show that these
are the two key factors in making people
profoundly happy I take five minutes out
of my day and pray to the creator and
none of the creations and I feel deep
internal peace and I still have my
normal life fiction somehow the idea got
into their minds that to kill other
people is a great thing to do and that
they would be rewarded in the here but
Christians do that every single day in
this country do they blow people up yes
so the Christians every day people walk
into post off I mean people walk into
post offices they walk into schools
that's what Columbine is I mean I could
do this all day long there's so there
are so many more examples of Christians
and I happen to be a Christian that's
back to this notion of you're idealizing
Christianity in my mind to my read
there's so many more examples ayianna of
Christians who do that then you could
ever give me examples of Muslims who
have done that inside this country where
you didn't work I think that we should
be able to put in listening devices in
there sure illegal search and seizure
but you know what anybody can toss away
the lesser-known amendments only it's
your Patriot can set a course straight
for the first we really have to consider
the given the fact so many people hate
us that we're gonna have to cut off
Muslim students from coming this country
for some period of time yes a religious
litmus test for school enrollment says
foxes most prominent liberal voice I
don't care if she knew about this she
ought to be in prison for wearing a
hijab Down Goes the ninth amendment
and culture doesn't just want a police
state she wants a fashion police state
it's killing of innocent human beings
human life is precious
[Music]
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking about the Boston bombing and
have been a tragic event Islam condemns
it yeah so tell us let's talk about
there's a lot of things that are going
to be on behind the scenes we're not
going to get into that again there's no
justification for it it doesn't matter
you know if for instance you can go
there's like hundreds of architects
engineers more than 1300 architects and
engineers examine the evidence about
building sevens collapse and disagree
with the official report issued by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology
I certainly am much more open-minded
about it than I was and it is because of
the involvement of the 9/11 families and
all these engineers and architects you
are about to hear from architect of 23
years Richard gage AIA member the
American Institute of Architects and
founder of architects and engineers for
9/11 truth now there are more than 1500
architects and engineers who say that it
could not have been brought down by
office fires they are backed by 9/11
family members who are calling for an
independent unbiased investigation I'm a
family member trying to find out the
answers to the murder of three
thousand-plus people
the bottom line is that it needs to be
investigated properly
please architects and engineers
people all around the world scientists
all around the world are questioning
this then there's some deep deep
explaining to do some kind of
consciousness-raising on my part before
I was willing to look at the the
possibilities and really you need to go
for the evidence leaves as an engineer I
have three degrees in engineering I
signed that petition for architects and
engineers for 9/11 truth some time ago
because the American people absolutely
need the truth of 9/11 look at the
evidence in fact I'll say this very
categorically any reasonable person who
looks at the evidence that's been
brought forward that's got to come away
with the feeling that something has to
be done a real investigation has to be
put forward
we will never heal this country will
never ever ever forget that day we have
to demand a new investigation I want
justice here
who are wanting to revisit 911 for
instance you know they're talking about
how can these buildings have come down
it seemed like a controlled demolition
we're not going to get into that you
know all the things that are behind the
scenes the entrapment and all of this
again Islam condemns it but now what can
be causing let's let's look to the route
what could be causing someone to just
flip out and snap and do something
horrific like this what are your
thoughts on that yeah obviously we don't
want to just look at the effect we have
to look at the cause you know as a
physician or anyone would like to so
it's very important as a fear human
being we have to look at the cause
anywhere when people are oppressed they
want to rebel and sometimes people take
up arms in a wrong way and go and kill
innocent people by the act of rebellion
some people they fight in just war or it
just fight so one reason could be when
people are oppressed they fight back
number one number two people may take
things out of context and people have
done that all throughout history when
the Crusaders when they came from Europe
and killed thousands of people Jews and
the Muslims they took things out of
context and that was their cause some
people do it out of money and greed and
power and name and fame you name it
people do it important for you and me
and all the fair-minded people do not
judge the faith ideology of those
individuals but the act that they're
committing so I think in a nutshell I
would say people are doing it not
because of the faith
definitely not because of Islam but
because of their own shortcomings and
misunderstandings of the wonderful
teachings of Islam whoever's whoever is
responsible is someone who now cannot
hide behind Islam that's clear
definitely clear they may be using
Arabic terminology they may be saying
Allahu Akbar god is great doesn't matter
if they are doing something heinous
doesn't matter what name that they call
to it what terminology that they use we
have to differentiate and distinct the
act compared to the wonderful teachings
of the Quran I mean it's because you
have a lot of Islamophobes people with
hate in their heart who it is a big
business
bashing the way of life from the crater
Islam the way that Jesus Moses Abraham
all the other messengers 124,000 they
were sent with the same message submit
to the crater not at his creation and do
good prepare for the day of judgment
Hellfire paradise it all makes sense is
logical but as big business now in this
this war on terror big business people
are getting paid big money right but
tell us we want to know doctor Sabeel
what can we do now because you know the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him who's
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind we didn't he didn't have or his
compendious victim mentality right like
you know the man's on top of us we can't
progress so what message do you have for
for the Muslims for those who are out
there confused there's a lot of
confusion right what message do you have
for wonderful as Muslims we have to be
optimistic we have to be positive and we
have to involve in the society first and
foremost do not judge Christianity or
Judaism by the acts of a few people of
their faith number one number two make
sure that you open your mosque your
masajid invite of our fellow Americans
that were fellow non-muslims so they
could come and see how we pray interact
with the Muslims and they could learn
the wonderful teachings of the Quran
number three it's a commandment for all
the Muslims Umrah bill maher roof owner
he and al-munkar and joined good and
forbid evil get involved in the society
better the society the Quran has
wonderful teachings and solutions for
all of humanity provide those solutions
to humanity and give the examples of and
live the example of Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him if somebody is
oppressing you or harming you smile at
them educate them and show them that
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him how
he in how he acted in the in the in the
in the midst of oppression how he
forgave the people when when he was he
had the chance to take them out because
of the oppression that they have done
and when he had the chance he had the
upper hand he forgave them when he
conquered Makkah right bloodless
conquest everyone was forgiven so
there's a message for our fellow
Americans
message for our fellow fellow people who
are not of the Islamic faith very
important again do not just the
wonderful teachings of Islam by some of
the misguided people who are doing this
act just like we don't want to judge
Christianity Judaism Hinduism by some of
their followers number one number two do
not judge Islam by looking at the Fox
News are looking at some of the
Islamophobes website and their videos if
you want to know Islam look at the Quran
and examine the life of Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him we could provide you a
free copy of the Quran call 866 - Islam
and gain peace and ignorable send you a
free copy number two number three if you
have any questions going ask a
knowledgeable Muslim and number four
come to the mosque of our mosque are
open for you come and interact with us
so let's all work together as the Quran
has mentioned so we could work for
justice and peace and establish a
society that is going to be a United
Society worshiping the one creator so we
could be blessed in this life and
wonderful time in the hereafter means we
have to go dr. Seville but in the last
minute we have people call this line
usually we have the number 1 800 662
they want to ask tough questions they
want to start a healthy dialogue even
some people you know they get sometimes
you know really emotional and aggressive
you had an aggressive call the other day
someone who was like you know what's up
with this Boston bombing what's
happening what's up it's all you Muslims
are we associated with this stuff tell
us about this what was the person's name
what happened and and what was the end
result yes so this person right after
the Boston bombing he called us on the
866 to Islam telephone line of game
peace he was very emotional he was very
attacking about to the Muslims and Islam
saying that how come loose limbs you're
doing this when we took the call we were
following the example of Muhammad peace
be upon him and we told him you know
do not judge Islam wonderful faith of
Islam but the actions of misguided
people we want to know Islam then we
explained to him what Islam is all about
and after knowing the wonderful
teachings of Islam on the telephone he
recited the Shahada or he became Muslim
he embraced Islam al hamdulillah he did
what Jesus did Moses and all the
messengers yes he started to submit to
the creator the way that all the
prophets did and now he has a purpose in
life
he has guidance for how to live his life
now he has a solutions for Humanity and
when he dies and when all of us dies
when we are with the guidance of God but
the mercy of God God is going to give us
paradise in the hereafter beautiful we
got to go you can call the number right
now call the number and ask your
questions learn pickup be open-minded
see what islam teaches we clearly said
it doesn't teach anything like what
you've seen in the Boston bombing and it
doesn't teach all of these evil things
that are attributed to it and you can
call right now 1-866 to Islam and never
more get you a copy of the free verbatim
would have got the crown thank you very
much for being with us welcome thank you
fighting the creative rewards you thank
you I mean and we thank you so much for
tuning in to the Deen show this way of
life submission to the will of the
creator not his creation worshiping the
creator not his creation your maker the
one who made you who you're going to
return back to the one who created the
Hellfire and the Paradise to reward you
when you do good you live good and
nowhere in this way of life is there
justification for someone to strap abana
Bhama myself and to go blow up a pizza
hut a subway shop Starbucks or marathon
we clearly have condemned this and we
wish that the CNN and the Fox News would
bring out incredible scholars people who
are living here in America where they
can talk to and learn directly from the
Muslims instead of bringing on many of
these these Islamophobes
these people who hate Muslims in Islam
who if they weren't hating on the
Muslims they be hating on African
American if they were hating on the
African America they be hating on the
Jew they weren't hating on somebody
they'd be hating on somebody else
there'd be somebody they'd be hating on
so come and sit with the Muslims we've
given you some great advice learn about
Islam learn about what it teaches
tune in I guarantee you
do you watch three four episodes of the
Dean show go to the Dean show comm to
see some of our previous shows look look
us up reviewed internationally all over
the globe you can watch us on YouTube
look at some of our shows call the 1-800
number pick up a verbatim word of God do
something sensible and I'm telling you
that that fog will be cleared and maybe
at the end you're truly discovered this
way of life that brings peace and
happiness and contentment so we'll look
forward to see you again next week here
on the Dean show until then peace be
with you
[Music]
[Music]
this is the
[Music]